and what bothers me about affirmative
action
is that it is essentially the government
saying
we will help you
when you're 18.
you can struggle from pre-k to 12th
grade in a crappy school
and we will not help you
but when you apply to college and turn
we're here to help you the good old
government
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th till february
28th bring to you the issues and
awareness that you need to know about
the violence on the south side of
chicago but also to raise as much money
as possible to build a community center
on this much needed block called oh
block it's called oh block because it's
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed and the gangs
took the o in his name and start calling
it o block we decided we're going to
keep it oh but we're going to change it
to opportunity block i want to thank fox
network for giving me the opportunity to
come to you every single day with my
rooftop revelations where i'm sharing
thoughts viewpoints and opinions as it
relates to things happening across
chicago and across our great nation
today i want to talk about a
controversial topic affirmative action
and i know some of you are asking what
the heck does affirmative action have to
do with my community well i'm here to
tell you a whole lot
right now the united states supreme
court has agreed to hear two cases
challenging admissions policies at
harvard and the university of north
carolina
i'm not going to go into all the depths
and details of both cases
because that is not the point of this
rooftop revelation
but both cases generally ask if racial
preferences can be used in college
admissions
my answer
is a simply flat out no
and for those of you wondering
no i've never used affirmative action
i've never benefited from it
i'm one of those folks that in the 2019
pew research center poll that found that
62 of black said that race should not be
used in college admissions
we all know it's a sham
i'm proud that i got to where i am
because i
worked hard and
gave it all that i had
[Music]
i know that many of my fellow brothers
and sisters
feel the same way
my problem with affirmative action is
that it helps nobody in our community
our schools are so bad that even our
smartest students struggle
to get the education that right that
they rightfully deserve
and what bothers me about affirmative
action
is that it is essentially the government
saying
we will help you
when you're 18.
you can struggle from pre-k to 12th
grade in a crappy school and we will not
help you
but when you apply to college and turn
we're here to help you the good old
government help you get into college
how in the world does that make any
sense at all
we're so far behind in this neighborhood
that it's not funny
when they graduate 12th grade some of
them are really at ninth grade levels
so we give them affirmative action and
all of a sudden
our students are years behind in college
many of these students aspire to be
doctors or
scientists
they choose those majors in college but
many simply cannot compete with students
from other schools
and what happens
they drop out or they switch to easier
majors
why are we doing this
we could have easily had those same
students
take a slower path upward community
college state college and then graduate
school
let them catch up let them keep their
dreams
several years ago
i saw a documentary called how jack
became black full disclosure the
producer of rooftop revelations eli
steele made this film
what struck me about the documentary is
that it explained that the original
purpose of affirmative action
the original purpose was to go into poor
underdeveloped communities
and provide better teachers
better funding
a pathway to opportunities
the problem was that this development
would take time though
university presidents wanted blacks on
their campus now so they
showed diversity and they switched from
the original purpose of affirmative
action to
racial preferences
they wanted blacks no matter what
they wanted blacks no matter where they
came from and the ugly truth is that
most blacks that benefited were middle
to upper class blacks
not the blacks from this neighborhood
so affirmative action has not helped us
one bit
here's an even uglier truth
the top colleges in america are fighting
over a small pool
very talented a small pool of very
talented black applicants who could have
gotten into colleges on their own
these colleges had no interest in
development
they wanted the quick easy fix
they wanted to look good and brag about
how many blacks they had on campus
it's simply tragic
tragic we we we need better schools not
affirmative action we don't need
handouts anymore
the bible says you reap what you sow
because our nation chose the path of
racial preferences
we're now in a racial war of sorts
what bothers me about these lawsuits is
how they discriminate even against
asians
i've been discriminated against and i
would not wish that on any person not
even my worst enemy
why in the world
would they discriminate against asians
that have worked hard and paid their
dues
what kind of america are we becoming
see what i'm getting at affirmative
action is poisonous
because it uses race as its primary
principle
this has allowed americans to overlook
developed black communities
this has allowed americans to
discriminate against asians
simply because they look different the
color of their skin
are you serious
this is why we need to do away with
affirmative action for once and for all
and if we do
then we will have nothing between us
and our problems
we won't have the lies we won't have the
lies the lies the lies of affirmative
action to hide behind
the problems will be raw naked and right
in front of us we will have to address
them
for once and for all
and that is why i support banning
affirmative action
as i always say thank you
for tuning in to my rooftop revelations
my thought my opinion my viewpoint until
tomorrow
peace
you